well the savings and loan crisis thing
is really struck a responsive chord
around the United States we've been
getting more mail from the programs
which we've done on the savings and loan
crisis with Rob Widdowson than any other
subject even those of the CIA or the
Kennedy assassination people are
astounded by it they want to hear more
about it
and you have a kind of come to Superstar
everybody getting these letters you know
they want to know about you and people
stopping you on the streets and not only
that rob has become one of the country's
experts and has been taken into the
confidence of some of the high
executives of these Savings and Loan
institutions investment bankers are our
colony month and spilling their guts to
him and business organization Colin tell
us what are we going to do how are we
gonna get out of this this is the
weirdest situation I think I've ever
seen and all this seems to be focused on
you because you I've been writing
articles and been on TV and people
recognize you and think you've got all
the answers well I don't have many
answers but I have been studying this
pretty carefully for a year and the more
I probe into it the more detail I see
naturally and so one of the problems is
that now that I've been doing it for so
long I have a kind of responsibility to
try and explain what I see have a
happening and what has happened to cause
this enormous financial disaster let's
say today if we can get the big picture
so for all the media has done in this
S&L crisis is to blame guys like Neil
Bush or Charles key Ian as if it's just
a few entrepreneurs that went berserk
rich kids gambling with the taxpayers
money that that's all the savings and
loan scandal really amounts to but
there's much more behind this isn't it
yes it appears that there were
structural changes in many areas that
relate to thrift the banking that really
created as much of this disaster as the
these evil SNL owners like Keating and
don't mean like changes in the laws and
policy or regulatory agencies and and
what the federal government did to these
people is just brutal I mean for those
people who are interested in conspiracy
theories I'm sure somebody can find
something I'm not going to come up with
anything right today but I mean there's
some threads in here that are really
nasty yeah but tell us about what some
of these changes apparently they made
changes and learn some of these naughty
guys in any way exactly that's exactly
that okay first of all it's pretty well
known that at the end of the 70s the
thrift industry was on the ropes because
of rising interest rates and the thrifts
had their money invested in long-term
mortgages and as interest rates on
deposits rose people took their money
out of thrifts and put them in money
market funds of banks and other agencies
that give him a high return
so now thrifts were carefully regulated
and had been all throughout their
history they were designed just for
single-family homes basically well in
1980 the first step was taken and that
was to lift the cap on interest rates
and raise the amount of insurance for
each deposit $200,000
okay now that one's pretty well-known
now in addition right around that time
because the thrift industry was in so
much trouble the regulator's began to
grant what they call forbearances now
part of the regular regulatory apparatus
was that each thrift had to maintain a
certain amount of freeze
serve money on hand it was calculated as
a percentage of assets assets being
outstanding loans and any property or
any other asset that the thrift owned
and they had to maintain 5% which means
that if the thrift was liquidated on a
given day they had to have at least 5%
left anything under that and they were
in violation of the rules and
technically they were insolvent they
could be closed but because the whole
industry was in trouble the regulator's
took it easy on him and they granted
forbearances which allowed them to carry
a lower capital reserve than the law
required now what that effectively meant
was see if you if you were a thrift
owner and that that 5% capital reserve
was really your profit because if you
liquidated the thrift on any given day
what was left over was what you took
home so in the early 80s with these four
when through in trouble
there were many of the thrifts had no
capital reserve which meant that the
owner had no more stake in the thrift he
already lost his money say so
so anything that he could grab the
antics in any way with his turn into
assets that could preper s'en allure
corporate that he could take control
outside of the framework and it so then
it meant that he really had no loyalty
to the organization exactly because he
had no money of it ah he had already
lost his money okay and this began
actually with Carter or when Reagan
first came in as president well the
problems in the thrift industry began in
the 70s and it dates back to us going
off the gold standard and floating
interest rates and all of that goes back
to Nixon really uh-huh exactly 70
and then the high inflation under Carter
and high interest rates exactly then
forced them to give a lot of money I was
getting 17% at one time yeah a little
part of certificate prime rate got up
over 20% when you grab it suddenly
anything so there's a point about the
psychology here the regulator's were
given everybody a break because they
didn't want to have to shut it shut it
all down they didn't have enough money
in the interest in the insurance fund to
cover all these deposits anyway the FSL
I say the FS LS a right so the owners
were kind of set up already
psychologically now in 1982 the famous
deregulation Act occurs and that's Garn
San Germain we've all heard about that
all the right
skulduggery and corruption went on in
that right well let me just go through a
couple of the provisions of garance and
remain and show how they have the kind
of effect they had first of all they
dropped the capital requirement from 5%
to 3% okay so that meant your reserves
had only to be 3% now that had an
interesting effect particularly with the
people that wanted to buy in okay they
need as much they didn't need as much so
if you had a hundred million dollar bank
a medium-sized thrift that was up for
sale in a small town in Texas for
example all you needed to come up with
was three million bucks to buy that bank
and you set that aside as a capital
reserve and you were off and running and
some people bought some very big banks
with even less than that yeah well
there's the famous stories of this
Florida guy uh-huh exactly with promises
that they were going to make it up and
they had investors and all of this now
the other another interesting part of
Garn San Germain was it allowed the
banks to take six percent loan
origination fee on any loan they made
now what that means is that you go into
a town you buy one hundred million
dollar bank you put up three million
bucks the next thing you do is you loan
that hundred million out and you take a
six percent loan origination fee and you
just put three million dollars
so you're being paid to loan money to
whoever there's any shady wheeler-dealer
here getting a letter and they took us
at the front and the government will
ensure the loan if it goes bad
exactly and you took it upfront so
you're encouraged to give bad loans by
this bill in a sense yes and they didn't
make any difference them if they were
paid back or not because they had their
6% exactly okay now the savings and
loans were allowed by garnish and remain
to branch out into all kinds of
investments in fact they were allowed to
invest directly in commercial real
estate projects so what they all did was
the minigun San Germaine was passed they
all set up a holding company
construction holding company sort of off
to the side and then they would loan
money to the construction company and
the construction company would go ahead
and develop property so the first thing
they all did was they designed office
towers and they counted on themselves to
be a primary tenant so they built
themselves buildings okay
they'll on themselves money built
themselves building right and then they
charged themselves absorbed in rent
which came out of the deposit Hawkins of
the savings in law exam he's at the end
there and they could take his profit and
their loan fee they got on top of all
the rest exactly exact God now another
thing they were allowed to do this is it
just gets more and more incredible a
hundred percent financing so borrower
comes into your back
he's got the project he wants to doing
these 50 million dollars well they never
asked him what he was going to give him
upfront they just said okay we'll enjoy
the 50 million they didn't have to put
up a dime they'd even check see the guy
with had credit were they well they were
supposed to check that it was called due
diligence but it was length left for
somebody else diligence I was lacking
his
eglee and as part of the deal they would
loan little extra like if you want a
fifty million they were lonely 58
million they'd set the 8 million side in
an escrow account to pay off the
interest the first years out premiums so
the developer never put in a penny the
bank loans out the 50 million bucks
right the payments are made on time
they're just pulled out of the escrow
account that the bank also learned as
part of the deal all right so the
developer didn't have to put up a penny
so this encouraged a lot of development
that wasn't needed I mean already
Houston for instance had about a fifty
percent vacancy rate on their office
buildings right in the throughout Texas
this was the case exactly now there's a
lot more and here in Austin we got all
these buildings and nobody's in yeah
exactly
now there's a reason for that and I'm
getting okay okay there's one other
point I want to make about Garn syndrome
a-all right
and this is really a killer they were
allowed to loan money on the appraised
value of a piece of property not on the
purchase price on the appraised value so
who is a present well you go around time
you get an appraiser but of course the
appraisers are going you know they
listen to the tone of your voice if
you're telling the tajmahal would you're
going to cover it with mosaics this big
and it's going to cost one hundred
million bucks well the you know suddenly
that's the prize exactly so I mean you
bought a piece of land for five million
dollars and you're going to put a
hundred million dollar development line
then a 100 million bucks was the
appraisal and that's how much you could
loan out and was the appraisers getting
kickbacks or were they getting
percentages based upon the appraisal
hungry
of course agenda standard fees huh right
exactly so okay now here comes a big
kicker one of the very first things that
Ronald Reagan did when you get into
office was he pushed through the tax
reform act
in 81 now there were two major clauses
of the Stax Reform Act one was it
dropped the tax rate for the very
wealthy the highest bracket from 78
percent 73 percent of 28 percent that's
a big guy that was a big drop freed up a
lot of bucks the second thing that it
did and this is the important thing for
the Savings and Loan industry is it
changed the way depreciation worked now
when you when you buy commercial
property you're allowed to depreciate
that property over the average length of
existence of that property so for
example if you buy a building for a
million dollars and it's got a 20 year
life let's say then you can depreciate
the value of that property five percent
every year for 20 years okay which means
that you can write that off your taxes
you take it off the gross your gross
income
well the Tax Reform Act of 1981 allowed
for accelerated depreciation so and
instead of 5% every year for 20 years
you could write off 12 percent the first
year 10 percent the second year 8
percent the third year so in 3 years
you've dropped 30 percent instead of 15%
okay
now what that meant was that you could
get an enormous tax break in fact most
of the people who invested went back and
refigured their taxes 3 years in advance
and took tax breaks on that too so they
made a fortune so they're defined tax
payments right there waiting to the
future to pay the taxes on it and
they're getting their deep discounts
early on is that the way it works well
when you're allowed to depreciate the
value of the property it means that yeah
you pay less tax at the beginning in
more tax okay okay says deferring the
[Music]
taxes l the the properties after three
or four years they wouldn't pay any
taxes
right exactly so what this did was
everybody wanted to build everybody
wanted to develop right so all as you
were saying all of that development all
of those properties were not built to
put people in their offices to meet
needs the people were known and there
was no market demand whatsoever right it
was a place to put your money and it was
an enormous tax shelter right okay now
this is going to come back to haunt
people okay now there's some other
changes there were changes in the
appraisers laws one key one was
something always troubled me was in 1983
and 1984 here in Austin along Congress
Avenue on Main Avenue all these office
towers went up all at once again some
notice that yeah okay and I always
bothered me I mean why was everybody
building at once and likewise
modern-style well the reason was that
the rules for phrases were changed
normally if you put up a property the
appraiser would have to take into
account the surrounding properties so in
other words if you put up a luxury
apartment building on a block with four
other luxury apartment buildings it's
worth less than if it sits by itself
right naturally market value well under
the new appraisal laws appraisers did
not have to take into account any
building in the area that was under
construction so in other words when they
appraised one of those towers on
Congress out they didn't have to take
into account the fact that there were
five other towers being built right on
the same street within a few blocks okay
so that the market value was completely
inflated for all of those towers
okay now you couple that with the fact
that you could loan on appraised values
and I mean you had an inflation that
went through the roof and people began
to do things called Lin flipping mm
where they would buy a property I'll
give you an example uh there's a guy
named Lou Reese Louie Reese from Dallas
he was a developer and in 1983 he bought
a property in DeSoto town just south of
Dallas 223 acre tract for 5.3 million
dollars a year later he set up a
partnership with a guy from Holland and
he sold the property to himself and the
partner for ten million dollars a year
after that that partnership sold the
property back to another Reese company
he sold it back to himself for fifteen
million dollars now what's the point of
this I'm not sure I understand the
financial benefit accrued from doing
this land flipping well he would borrow
the money from a bank to sell the
property from himself to himself so he
would take the Prophet himself exactly
okay okay and and the way you would do
it is he did an appraiser to appraise
the land at a higher value each time and
this was called land flipping and it was
very common in fact one developer told
the story of being in a courthouse
County Courthouse near Dallas one
afternoon and a real prime piece of
property was up for sale and what they
did was they lined a hallway in front of
the County Clerk's office with card
tables I'm here the story and now it was
incredible with the card tape okay so
the deed comes and sits on the first
card table here's the buyer here's the
seller they sign everything pass papers
all the checks but then they pass the
deed to the next card table new buyer
same property same property right and
they pass it down this line
would go up every each time the value
would rise okay now where was the money
where was the money coming in to do this
I mean there yeah that's right each
buyer at the battle had had it borrowed
from savings in less so that increases
the debt so every time they do this they
put in their pocket the profit but they
increase the debt that's exactly
borrowing from the SNL's or whoever to
finance these actions so the debt grows
it doubles every time they you know
double the price that's right of this
things this is how the debt doubles and
sky rocks it's that's exactly right
that's how all of these these inflated
values took place now each each borrower
would have its own appraisal and it
would have its own idea for the property
okay so if we're going to build a Taj
Mahal
somebody might want to paint it somebody
else might want to put mosaics this big
well that's gonna cost you more okay so
all of this development was like the
figment of people's imagination now at
the same time we're in the early 80s
Congress passed the law that said that
savings and loans could go use new
accounting procedures here's another
change in an Associated industry the
accountants the way it works was uh
let's say you had a piece of property
and he sold and there was a $20,000 loss
just for fun never happened in those
days but let's say it was a twenty
thousand exactly well in the old days
before these new accounting procedures
were put in you had to say minus twenty
thousand and subtracted out of weight of
your net worth
well these new accounting changes
allowed you to spread that loss over
twenty years so you could divide it so
you lose twenty thousand you spread it
over twenty thousand or twenty years you
subtract one thousand dollars each year
so even though you took the hit in 1983
for example it never showed up on
so it was like deferring the taxes is
deferring the losses and exactly and so
the boost looked great I mean you lose a
thousand bucks away come on the whole
thing is a fairy tale then exactly it's
like fantasy finance a whole thicket of
capital exactly the whole thing was made
up okay
it was a daydream it's now our nightmare
but it was a daydream then now at the
same time remember and by the way the
accountants were also following the same
pattern as the appraisers the
accountants were supposed to be
independent auditors who went in and
looked at the books okay but remember
there would be a paid a fortune to do it
and so I mean one of the prime examples
for example is Keating his parent
company was called ACC American I know
he went to Arthur Young in 1986 and the
now they they were making about 20
million dollars a year gross Keating
ghost woman says I've got a three
million dollar account here and I want
you guys to cooperate how naturally
they're going to cooperate they're going
to do any thousand exactly exactly and
of course two years later the guy who
was in charge of that account suddenly
left his job at Arthur Young and took a
job with Keating for a million dollars a
year
I mean joining all of Keaton's siblings
we were getting over a million a year
exactly salaries exactly so now the
other factor was the bank board itself
now the way the Savings and Loan
industry was arranged was the federal
overseer of all of the savings and loans
was called the Federal Home Loan Bank
board they had an office in Washington
and then they had 12 regional offices
and they had a dual function they were
there to support the Savings and Loan
industry for example each of the twelve
offices had a bank
no bank and they would lend savings and
loans in their jurisdiction money if
they needed it they would support them
in various ways and they would promote
them they would help with advertising
and all kinds of stuff but at the same
time they were the regulators so I mean
they had this dual schizophrenic role to
play and for most of the time the
savings and loans existed the first 40
years there was no problem because they
were mom-and-pop industry everybody was
pretty honest nobody megan Achille
anyway but when these other changes
started to take place and things started
to explode nobody changed the regulatory
structure so there was this intense
coziness okay between the regulators and
the examiners and the banks themselves
we give you an example yeah right here
at the University of Texas at Austin
there's a gentleman whose name is Robert
Medellin now Medellin is an expert in
the world of thrift finance
okay that's his field and apparently is
quite good at it from 1983 to 1985 he
sat on the board of directors of Lamar
Savings the biggest SNL in town right
exactly
also the biggest bailout in town that's
how our alternative years account as
well as my house well you'll be very
interested in this so Madeleine was on
the board of directors of Lamar Savings
he was also on the board of directors of
Lamar Financial Corporation which was
the holding company that owned Lamar
savings hey he was also at the very same
time from 1982 to 1987 the head of the
regional bank board so he was the head
bank examiner responsible for Lamar
Simmons
at the same time he was on their board
and both boards as boards and is in 1984
he was named the Lamar saving Centennial
professor of Savings and Loan finance at
the University of Texas which means is
that an endowed chair which means he
gets a hell of a lot of money for
teaching over and above what professors
normally exactly and that that course
that had Amin came from Lamar savings
and and I said the circle here oh well
it gets better it was also on the Austin
Chamber of Commerce which was of course
regulating or in promoting all this
growth and he was the University of
Texas vice president for development
that was also promoting growth and
development exactly mm-hmm so with
certain savings and loans finance a more
I you know cozy I guess is hardly
conveys the kind of content such jurist
occupied well it's just a typical inside
game of most regulatory agencies and
their clients huh exactly but this is
just a little little more egregious
there is a difference here though I
think the philosophical underpinnings of
all this is the Reaganite philosophy of
deregulation let the market solve all
the problems be it banking or
development or savings alone or whatever
so this is really the major example of
Reagan's deregulation running a month
pretty early on early on the Garn San
Germain was touted as the triumph of the
Reagan Revolution of the deregulatory
policies being extended to the whole
realm of finance well that's true but
you say the realm of Finance and
remember one of the key the
underpinnings of Finance is the notion
of
and there was no free market here there
was no free market at all because all of
that money was guaranteed guaranteed
right so it was a joke right it was a
myth
so socialism for the gamblers for then
the market for the play was they were
there just counterfeit they were just a
legal counterfeiters right without
restraint so what's happening here is
that the government was with opening all
the doors come in let him by the hand
open the cookie jar say hey we're going
to live here now and you folks sick yeah
no don't you dare touch that cookie jar
yeah if you screw up and spoil all the
cookies will give you know giving more
cookies yeah exactly we got plenty in
the back so you know just to what really
happened was now at the same time of
course all the thrifts are are pulling
in deposits from all over the country
the insurance is a insured deposits at a
hundred thousand these hundred thousand
dollar CDs broker deposits from all of
them so the money's pouring in the
thrifts are pouring it out okay there
are pain developers who are overcharging
them who are paying architects
appraisers who are overcharging who are
contractors who were overcharged
everybody skim and everybody's taken
there was a piece of the action
okay so the boom is well underway
everything's going fine now they've got
to pay high interest rates on these
deposits to attract them and that's
taken a big cut what's probably even a
bigger cut is the the lifestyle I mean
they they built these office towers they
had to buy planes because they had to
fly over these tracts of land to look at
them and they're doing deals all over
the country now limousines to take them
there where exactly they had all of
these haul girls to entertain their
clients exactly promotional parties ed
McBurney spent two million bucks on
three parties you know six percent loan
origination fees
you know you're bringing in a lot of
bucks to get used to driving a Mercedes
get tired of the Mercedes you buy
yourself a Lamborghini and so forth well
this doesn't sound like mom-and-pop
anymore who used to own the S&L so we do
guess his whole new stratum of scumbags
and charlatans move into the S&L
industry exactly over in fact there was
a big split in the industry right that
took place during this several of the
old-timers would own savings and loans
for years refused to play and they just
kept doing the same thing they'd been
doing they were laughed at by the high
flyers who said man were everybody's
making a kill and let's go but they
refused and in fact there was a almost a
like a little secession there was a
secession in a sense from the US League
of saving institutions which was the
main organization National Organization
several of these more conservative first
drop-down and in fact there are about
1,500 healthy thrifts left in the
country most of them are those that
didn't play the guy exactly state
concern so there might be a lesson there
somewhere now we got the book going and
then all of a sudden a bunch of forces
began to converge as we've said is high
interest rates they were Penn the
high-flying living high higher cost of
living in 1985 oil prices dropped been
up to $30 a barrel suddenly dropped to
11 okay so right away several of the
developers and investors who were
putting together these enormous projects
that the savings and loans were funding
defaulted
now that started the slide this around
80 seconds is a t568a hot okay okay
in 86 came the big hit okay and the big
hit was the second Tax Reform Act at the
Reagan years in which he renamed on all
of the deals of the first tax reform act
so in other words accelerated
depreciation retro actively
retroactive retro actively suddenly they
had to refigure all the taxes back on a
straight-line life of of the asset basis
hey okay I want my cookies back to say
where but they flushed down that made
the her that's right on the Arkansas all
of these people who had taken this
enormous tax break suddenly had to make
it up had to make it up and so they all
I mean almost a hundred percent
defaulted on their heels they couldn't
make any payments the escrow accounts
that were set up as the original part of
the deal were running out and all of
these deals fell apart now the
developers were in another serious bind
because when a property was foreclosed
the and if the SNL forgave the dead
didn't chase you the IRS treated that
forgive forgiven dad as income and so if
you were forgiven $700,000 debt then
they sent a little form to the IRS and
they are arrested what US taxes on
$17,000 plus any depreciation that they
did get from the now straight-line
depreciation was treated as capital
gains so they had to pay capital gains
tax on what they had written off so
everybody declared bankruptcy I mean
it's a joke now but if you look at the
curves by year of bankruptcies in Texas
it goes
and then bow like that and that's the
reason I mean they just had no choice so
now the dream is over
party's over the party's over hangover
is very happy that's right and so all
the savings and loans now have to
foreclose now when they foreclose in
most of these deals the property was set
up as collateral so now all the savings
and loans suddenly are taken in all this
property now they're taking in apartment
buildings they're take in developments
that have a few roads in them and they
got the Golf Course up that now people
live in there's nothing there I empty
office buildings they got nothing now
this is their these foreclosed
properties are called real estate -
owned on the books of the the banks so
there's known as REO property for short
REO was a real problem
for banks savings not because first of
all they had to take care of him and he
got apartment building somebody's got to
manage it somebody's had to get to rent
somebody's gotta clean em of maintenance
all of that they gotta pay taxes if you
got a development that was half finished
- it and uh suddenly they were in the
serious development business and they
didn't want to be so that was the first
problem the second problem was that REO
was subject to regulatory write down
okay now because that may well
the regulator's would come in and they'd
look at the REO that you had on your
books if you were counting out they were
supposed to be trying to sell us to get
back their investment if you couldn't
sell it the regulator's would come in
and actually arbitrarily drop the value
yeah
well which was realistic though exactly
because it wasn't selling or I wasn't
even developed in some case I didn't
have the capital to complete the project
that's right but you can see what this
did to the bank to the to the Savings
and Loan all right the profits go down
no more bonuses based on profits their
capital reserve go down now they're
technically insolvent and the
regulator's are banging on the door to
close them in one case you can examine
other-- example from Lamar here in town
they had a development out on route 22
22 I went to town here enormous
development golf course little water
company and made water some 1,200 homes
many of them in the high dollar bracket
it's called River place well they sank
63 million dollars into River plants
when they foreclosed on it they got I
think 100 homes the golf course and the
water company in the land the roads over
time the regulator's wrote it down and
the eventual final write down value was
five million dollars so on that one deal
Lamar lost gone forever 58 million
dollars which was actually in the
pockets of all the people to start out
with that's rank people and the
construction people
well now is the appraisers everybody who
skimmed some of the action so the money
is gone but it's gone somewhere else in
their pockets or an offshore banks or
that's ready ia or mafia and the whole
thing remember that the whole value was
originally inflated yeah by those
appraised values by by all of that
so REO property was an enormous problem
for the SNL's and this is where the
owners the executives stepped over the
line
okay now they've been living the high
life for a few years legally huh legally
originally right okay even though we
know it's a figment of their imagination
it was legal but now they got all this
REO and they got to get it off their
books so they developed some schemes to
get it off their books
one thing they did for example was a
simple deal called a sham transaction
can you got a friend okay
you were the owner of the bank you sell
apartment building to your friend and
you write into the deal you will not be
held responsible for this loan if you
have to foreclose and they put in the
interest and all that and you know you'd
be allowed to take couple hundred
thousand dollars out of the operating
expenses or you get your money somehow
okay
now what this did was it took the REO
off the books gave it to you while I'm
looking for a buyer but I didn't have
any responsibility because in contract
said if I default it I wouldn't be held
exactly there was a case here in telling
for example another Lamar case the owner
had a friend named an Indian guy
DJ Parikh and there was a apartment
building here in town that was REO and
lamar sold the building to vijay parikh
and during the trial he was tried and
convicted fraud during the trial it came
out that Parikh didn't know how much the
loan was that he was getting what the
interest rate was what the payments were
I mean he just didn't know anything they
just they just gave him the money to
take the take the thing off the off
their hand right and of course nobody
really exchanged hands they just said
the apartment buildings in your name and
you just borrowed you know the worth of
the apartment building from us right and
it's up to him to develop it and to run
it yeah exactly he held it for six
months or so and actually he was
actually pretty good property manager
apparently and then a buyer was found
and it was sold he didn't even know the
name of the buyer by the way when it
happened to sold his own property you
know so if there's all of them buy them
are yeah yeah so this was just a way to
hide get it off the books and yeah so
these are the kinds of transactions that
most of the indictments that you read
about in the papers are focused on this
is after 86 or 87 86 and after was most
85 86 when most of these deals went down
well how about some of these things that
they did you told my previous program
where SNL's would sell their bad assets
to another SNL when they knew the bank
examiners are coming in and then when
the bank examiner left then that SNL
would sell them back to the original SNL
those were called daisy chains yeah now
this is the same product legal or those
earlier oh they're illegal because it's
it's a means of hiding the true worth of
the bank from the regulator's so they
had a whole bunch of these schemes
exactly but they were all focused around
this REO which happened after 86 and 85
when oil prices dropped and more
importantly when the other tax the
second tax reform Act came through and
and effectively cut the legs off of the
industry well I just wanted to clear up
a couple of other
kinds of deals that may light okay okay
there was one we've already talked about
daisy chains and if it was just to
savings and loans it was called trading
a dead horse for dead cow I can't take
my dead cow take your dead horse there
was also a kind of transaction called
cash-for-trash okay and this has become
quite important as is the thing that
they're after Silverado about it sound
like a TV program then exactly well it's
sort of a word add game show yeah that's
what it was like because here was the
deal
if developer came to the bank and said I
need fifty million dollars to develop
this development the bank would say fine
we'll only fifty million but actually we
want to loan you sixty nine and you take
that extra ten million and use it to buy
some REO from us so it was another way
to get REO off the books now remember I
was telling about this land flip up in
Dallas with Lou Reese who 5.3 million
you sold it to himself a couple times 10
15 even ride well in 1985 Lamar savings
contracted with Lou Reese to buy the
property from himself again this time
for twenty eight and a half million
dollars two years before he paid 5.3 for
but they loaned him thirty seven million
dollars
now the extra was transferred to another
company that looked a resound and that
company used that money as down payment
for two shopping centers
that Lamar owned that they had to
foreclose on except so that's plan an
inside game of circulating your bed
investment exactly so once again another
trick to get REO off your books and was
this the illegal
this was very illegal and in fact for
lamar executives have were indicted two
weeks ago for this was one of the
transactions that was named in these and
what about Eddie Reese Alton Lee did his
development projects flop I think I saw
something on TV about uh-huh well he
says that he took the twenty eight
million and he put it into developing
this property this tesota property and
he had a deal with Lamar that six months
later once he had the structural things
in that they would lend him more money
to build the homes and so forth and he
claims that when he went back to Lamar
to get more money they reneged and said
they were going to give him anymore
Lamar says that they were going to give
him anymore because he pocketed ten of
the twenty eight million dollars which
of course he did
I mean what would you do so REO is the
problem now there was a bank in Denver
Colorado that's gotten quite famous now
called Silverado and one of the reasons
they're famous is they had a nifty
creative way to get rid of REO now of
course this is the one where Neil Bush
is on them
in fact Silverados kind of a classic
example of many of these things that
we've talked about they use these
structural changes to build Silverado
into an enormous dream when the bubble
burst they just liked everyone else had
all this REO property what they did was
they set up a little holding company off
to the side and they dumped all their
REO and all the company now this was
called the loan pool and then when
developers came to them they loaned them
much more than the asking and developers
asked for and the developers would then
buy stock in the loan pool with the
extra money with the extra money I would
keep the bad investment cynical a yeah
and looking great so they put these all
these profits on their books I say now
Silverado was notorious they did they
had at every time they had been examined
they had been warned and cited for
excessive bonuses excessive salaries
insider loans michael woz was the
chairman he Silverado loaned him two and
a half million dollars on which he
defaulted the major stockholder was a
guy named Mets I loaned him one and a
half million and he defaulted the old
Bush's companies got millions of dollars
exactly and they got millions of dollars
from two developers that did many of
these deals with Silverado Ken good and
Bill Walters and in fact the indictment
the charges against Neil Bush are
focused on specific transactions
involving those two guys and they of
course it helped him set up his oil
exploration company and so he was known
to his business partners exactly had a
conflict of interest cuz he was on the
bank for exactly now it's funny because
I'm laughing because
during his testimony before Henry
Gonzalez is banking committee he was
trying to explain his relationship with
bill Walters and Frank annunzio said so
your partner was borrowing money from
the bank and you were approving the
loans and and Bush said no no no no
Walters was a partner in my company but
I wasn't a partner with him
so Frank annunzio representative
annunzio calls this the principle of
Partners interruptus that sounds like
Neil Bush you make a good vice president
well I'm sure he had the the advice of
his dad who was considered an expert in
this field he headed the yeah he headed
the White House task force to oversee
deregulation of the SNL industry and it
would grants to me like the worst person
possible to get financial advice
pantheon because this is such a disaster
that's all
operator that's right but see in 1983-84
it appeared the Jewish was on top of
things well and he studied the industry
very carefully and Edwin who was on the
committee with him said that in
testimony before Congress he said that
he was delighted to serve with Vice
President Bush because Bush was so
knowledgeable about the savings alone
industry now in 85 86 when the lens got
cut out
and that's when Neil Bush went on the
board and 1985
so his timing was bad yeah one could say
that now there's some other things about
Silverado you know in 1987 they were
subject to a big examination and the
examiners recommended that it be closed
a guy named Kermit Mowbray who was the
head of the regional bank board and who
was the one
issue the order declined to do so and
said they're good guys down there let's
work it out with them and so they were
allowed to stay in business for another
year and in the summer of 88 they were
told that they had to come up with sixty
two million dollars in cash by October
13th or they were going to be closed now
it was right around this time that Neil
Bush resigns because his dad had been
nominated for to run for president of
party interestingly enough on October 13
when the day that they were supposed to
close Silverado actually on October 12th
Kermit Mowbray who was supposed to issue
the order got a mysterious phone call he
can't remember from home from Washington
that said delay the closing of Silverado
and so Silverado was not closed until
November 9th one day before like Sunday
after the other after the election so
that it couldn't become part of the
election exactly now a total cost the
taxpayer hard to tell one and a half
billion probably for us so Silverado
loan five executives have been barred
from the industry for life and charges
are going to be brought against Neil
Bush he could have accepted a deal but
he chose to fight and it appears that
the office of Thrift Supervision is now
going to seek a two hundred million
dollar lawsuit against the board
including bush all over Washington
there's posters jail Neil Bush I was in
Washington DC last week this is a very
big issue there but I think there's
scapegoating him he was just one of
hundreds maybe thousands of wheelers and
dealers who were playing these games and
everything I've read about Bush he was
pretty light in the head and he wasn't
very intelligent he was just any sort of
suckered into these things well Michael
Weiss pulled him into Silverado
obviously for his name you know his
political connections it wasn't the bush
had any expertise or that he even knew
what he was doing well he had some
experience in banks he had been a clerk
in a bank as a summer job when he was in
college because they are service
experience that qualified him to be on
the board but you know he knew Walters
and good they'd invested in his company
wise Walters and their common lawyer
they all shared a lawyer we're all
members of a Chamber of Commerce at the
same time I mean they were just all cozy
with friends now let's together Rob
what's the complicity of Congress in all
of this so far we've seen that the
Reagan deregulation and just stupid
banking rules gone amok caused the
problem in the first place which was
compounded by the change in the tax laws
that made the situation worse that you
didn't know what the game rules were
anymore now Congress is supposed to have
some responsibility well they did it
first of all they they passed the to tax
reform acts for one thing and and the
Garn San Germain and the the cat lead
lifting off the cap on deposits they
approve the changes and accounting
procedures edwin gray went to congress
he testified before several
congressional committees in 1994-1995
he warned this was going to happen he
said there's going to be an enormous
taxpayer bailout you guys are being
crazy he put in regulations Congress
gutted those regulations so Congress is
the Cobblers got rid of gray right
exactly they were doing
I knew him yeah he was the only honest
guy no and they brought in a crony
insider in the industry Danny won't
Danny Roth we start this program by
talking about the Southwest plan which
was hatched up by Danny wall who had
been the replacement for Edwin gray as
head of the Bank board the infamous
Southwest plan which was an enormous
giveaway I had that word well after a
8687 when the industry was falling apart
the bank board was going in and taken
over all of these insolvent thrifts I
mean they were they were losing money
daily ten million dollars a day was
pouring out so it behooves the industry
to take over these thrifts but when they
did they had to pay off the deposits
they had to pay off the interest and so
forth now the according to the charter
of the FS LIC the insurance corporation
all thrifts paid insurance premiums into
a pool and that pool was rapidly
depleted in 1987 a boost to that pool
was passed through Congress of
11 billion hey the federal government
just put the money in till they loaned
it to the to the FSL SC and by the way
of Jim Wright resigned over machinations
of this 11 million dollars but anyway
that's another story
and Coelho also resigned us because he
was compromised by the SNL uh-huh okay
fine yeah that's right that's right with
Columbia savings and it was also a good
friend of Mike Milken span again that's
another story so uh with the bank board
taking over all these threats all the
money disappeared real fast now it's
1988
there are 197 looting savings and loans
and the Southwest mainly in Texas
they're hemorrhaging money out
it's a and the insurance fund is broke
so Danny Walters now the head of the
Bank board decides that what he's going
to do is work out a deal with wealthy
capitalists around the country to buy up
these banks so that the bank board won't
have to take him over so he's got to
convince these guys to buy these losing
propositions okay so here's what he did
first of all we packaged them up uh you
know 10-year 20-year and he went to
these wealthy folks Robert Bass one of
the Hunts a guy named the Pearlman Ron
Perlman's head of Revlon Corporation and
James failed who we'll talk about in a
minute and all of the deals although
many of them are still secret they all
as far as we can tell shared some common
characteristics and here's the way they
went down the bank board would go to the
investor with a list of the assets the
investor would choose the assets that he
would take responsibility for obviously
the performing loans the the ones that
were worth a lot of money and so forth
all of the bad assets the defaulted
loans the REO there was no good and so
forth he still owned because the bank
board couldn't take it they didn't have
any organization or any money to do it
bad Bank said we will guarantee those so
if you've got a non-performing loan
don't worry about it we'll pay it and
we'll give you a promissory note right
here from the federal government okay
for ten years we'll pay off all of those
bad assets to get insurance policy Wow
you know what the investors say the
potential investor said no dude we want
to make some profit on our money Danny
well said no sweat we'll give you 2
percent profit on everything all the
badass will not only pay him off we give
you 2 percent you guys said land I don't
know uh you know I've got to chase these
people I've got to hire lawyers I had to
litigate this stuff no problem we'll pay
the lawyers fees whether they're
successful or not
we being the federal government federal
government that's right and how much
money did he have to do these that's the
well where did you get it well he didn't
get it you go ahead you buy the right
track oh yes I'll use well the original
value of the notes and of course there
were very optimistic expectations about
some of these people picking up payments
even though they hadn't paid for two
years and this kind of stuff
and so the estimate by the bank board at
the time was twenty four point five
million dollars to close these these
thrifts or to sell them right now it's
close to fifty billion and most experts
give a range of seventy-five to a
hundred billion for just this these
there were fifteen transactions and this
is just in the southwest the Southwest
Brides called the Southwest plan now
that's what they were saying the entire
bailout bill was going to be a few
months ago exactly no now catch this one
guy who's been in the news quite a bit
lately as guy named James fail he's a
he's a insurance guys and insurance
companies and in 1976 one of his
companies was convicted of a felony
fraud and he was indicted but he copped
a plea and got out of it but he was
barred from selling insurance in the
state of Alabama he's also been barred
from several other states for various
mal practices so he comes along and he
buys as part of the Southwest plan
fifteen failed savings and loans he
packages them together calls it blue
bonnet savings and he goes into business
well how did they let him do that if he
was such a bad guy well that's funny you
would mention that he hired a lobbyist
guy named Robert Thompson now Thompson
is an interesting guy because he's a
close friend of Prescott Bush jr. George
Bush's brother
and in fact in 1979 this lobbyist
Thompson was actually on George Bush's
campaign staff when he was gone for
presidency and in 1980 when Bush became
vice president Thompson became a
legislative aide a liaison between
Congress and the White House so he got
to know everybody and in 1983 you quit
his job he goes into the lobbying
business and the first thing does he
sends out promotional Flyers on Thompson
and company stationery that says he has
breakfast once a month with George Bush
so he had successful lobbying business
souther 1988 James fail comes along
since I want a piece of the Southwest
plan action can you help me the guy says
no problem Thompson and Thompson takes
all of the documents through the
approval process where they're supposed
to look and see if this guy's have been
by felons and whatever and
some of the forms disappear the dead
boxes don't get checked ride and
son-of-a-gun
fail ends up with Bluebonnet savings now
Bluebonnet savings has three million
three billion dollars in total assets
Jay 1.85 is guaranteed those promissory
notes from the government
okay now fail paid 70 million dollars to
get into that deal so he got three
billion dollars for an initially had to
put in his own capital 70 million
dollars
well that 70 million he borrowed some of
it from his own insurance company what
he actually put up out of his own pocket
was $1,000
he got thirty billion and I read that
three billion for $1,000 I wouldn't give
them 2,500 you know why don't they talk
to me so interestingly enough in 1989
just to finish this story Bluebonnet
savings was the single most successful
most profitable thrift now thrifts are
there to make loans guess how many loans
Bluebonnet savings made in 1989
thousands for big ones perfect one of
three of which I don't know about one
was to a lobbyist named Robert Thompson
three hundred and fifty thousand dollars
no kidding so Phil got his his banks
even though he wasn't eligible because
of his previous history Thompson got his
path and got his head plus he got two
percent of the profits from Bluebonnet
in the first several years who fell this
the law yes yeah two percent now as
Thompson in jail yet no a wouldn't you
kidding he's a good friend to Prescott
Bush
well how does breakfast with George Bush
every my real how did he get the two
percent of the
and profit I was just part of the
doubles part of the deal yeah Oh take 2%
so that's the Southwest plan and that's
considered to be one of the most
egregious offenses in this whole nasty
story and this was this particular part
came from the regulators so this was a
Danny wall arranged the message of all
this seems to be that every time
Congress tries to do something to deal
with this SNL crisis they do something
that makes things worse and when the
federal regulatory apparatus sticks
their hand in the pie and they try to
fix up clean up the mess they make it
even worse has this been the
accelerating story of the worsening of
the crisis of the S&L this is the way
your story sounds to me exactly now if
you think about it there were three real
strong players here there's there's
Congress and the legislative apparatus
including the White House and then
you've got the regulatory apparatus here
and then you've got the savings and
loans suppliers to players and if you
listen to the play to the players and
the SNL's they're blaming the
regulator's the regulators are blaming
Congress Congress is blaming the SNL
guys
sounds like didn't you any a blame to go
around everybody's however however some
of the regulator's were in bed of course
we talked about interacting in bed with
the industry but the good guys the
regulator's who were taking their jobs
seriously and we're trying to keep
things under control like Edwin gray who
was head of the Bank board Congress
kicked him out and the bank examiners in
California who were trying to to make
Keating toe the line with Lincoln
Savings they were stomped on by the boys
higher up fives right yeah
people were trying to investigate
Florida and some of the problems down
there and they were given a hard time by
both Congress and the people they were
trying to investigate exactly and he
goes even further than that
Edwin gray in 1984 when he realized he
started to see what was going on he said
first of all they slashed the budget of
the regulator's slashed it by more than
half over the previous few years so he
had minimal staff it was two three years
before they got back into a bank after
an examination between examinations to
three years sometimes and the salaries
were incredibly low all of the good
people had been sucked out and gone into
other organizations like the FDIC for
example and what they had was a bunch of
people that just got out of college we
were looking for job you know they got
something twenty six thousand a year or
something like that and they were the
ones responsible for trying to figure
all this stuff out in fact I was talking
to one of the executives at Lamar during
this period and he told me about a
regulator now this is a guy you know
he's been in the business 20 years and a
regulator 26 years old comes in he's got
six months experience he's sitting there
and he's going through these folders and
his eyes are crossing and the executive
is is pointing things out and saying
right now don't forget to look at this
here and see this year and here's the
list for due diligence over here you
know so the now gray went to he was his
apparatus was controlled by OMB the
Office of Management and Budget so gray
called David Stockman who was in charge
at the time and he said David help I
need more people I need better salaries
I gotta have some money and Stockman
said wait a minute you mean you want
more regulation this is the era of
deregulation you want more regulation
that's tantamount to treason and he
wasn't kidding they were talking he's an
ideologue he was a hardcore deregulation
we'll solve all problems exactly and and
Ed gray for all his
the goodness of spirit was derisive Lee
known in Washington and as the great
reregulate er that was the label that
they they stuck on him because
deregulation run amok the situation got
nothing but worse a bush comes into
office and he presents a bailout package
this is 89 now this is 18 early 89 and
now his first actions as president
exactly 28 days or something into his
presidency and a lot of the package was
based in what he had learned in 1984
when he was head of the White House task
force to oversee deregulation and they
had proposals then that they chose not
to present but some of them were
incorporated into the bailout bill of
last summer which was called phi rhea
the federal institution recovery Reform
and Enforcement Act you gotta have an
acronym or exactly is that you're not
done something deport nine the
bureaucrat to Bush bail out that's what
I call it anyway there was an
interesting provision in the bush
bailout that I want to bring up here now
remember we had the Tax Reform Act of
1981 and then the Tax Reform Act of 1986
that reversed all of those changes and
effectively cut the industry down now in
the bailout bill there was there's a
little clause that says goodwill is no
longer valid
okay now goodwill was something that the
bank board had offered during the time
when all the when the SNL's were
starting to ash again they were looking
for ways to shore up insolvent SNL's
without putting any money in because
lots of during lots of that period there
was no money in the insurance fund so
the regulator's worked out deals if
there was an insolvent thrift let's say
there's a thrift that had was
50 million in the red they would go to a
nearby thrift and they would say we want
you to buy that bad thrift and that's a
well that's crazy why should I do that
I'm going to lose 50 million bucks and
then I'm insolvent the bank board said
no sweat we if you buy that thrift we
will give you something called goodwill
50 million dollars worth you can put it
on your books and so your books will be
balanced and you'll help us out and
you'll get that other thrift and when
the bank examiners come along they have
to add in this 50 million on the profit
side so that you know your books aren't
crashed by this insolvent Savings and
Loan
so there were all these institutions
around the country who had bought up
other insolvent thrifts to help out the
Bank board and they have taken on
goodwill in good faith
now the bailout bill comes along in 1989
I remember the bailout bill bailing out
approximately 275 to maybe 300 badly
insolvent trips fifty billion dollars
run then in the bailout bill it says
goodwill is no longer valid
so this thrift it had a 50 million
dollar-plus suddenly it's gone
evaporated and it's insolvent out there
insult and so if you remember six months
after the bailout bill suddenly they
announced that oops another 500 thrift
couldn't meet the capital requirements
they were going to go down that adds why
it was the damn goodwill so it made it
worse so every time that there's a
government action is it intensifies in a
qualitative way mushroom exponential
works better yeah exactly I mean
something like this is just I mean
that's why at the beginning of the
program I said something about
conspiracies I mean it is so obvious
that you'd think that it's intentional I
saw an article that the in the Dallas
newspaper that the regulators are
wanting to renege on the Southwest plan
and make that retroactive now is this
part of what you're talking about well
there's that something ii renew to them
well it's it's a slightly new
development part part of this has to do
with james fail the blue bonnet savings
guy because they're saying that he
obtained his Southwest plan deal
fraudulently because the papers that
were submitted weren't clear about his
past history which would have barred him
from participating so that's one aspect
of why they're going to renege on his
deal but in addition what they're saying
is you remember the deal was that all
the bad assets that the investor the
buyer chose not to take control the
government said they would guarantee and
that agreement with those are called
yield maintenance agreements they would
maintain the yield on this loan even if
it was defaulted on okay so in other
words you've got you loan out some money
the guy defaults he's not giving you any
payments anymore and the investor fail
Houston for example has to take that
loan as part of the Southwest plan and
the government said we'll make the
payments see that's what the guarantee
is we'll make the payments will give you
2 percent profit and we'll pay your
legal fees okay and we'll give you 2
percent profit on the legal fees yeah ok
don't forget that so what the government
is saying now is that those agreements
means that if effectually the government
bought that loan and it belongs to the
government
okay so now they're going to say yeah
all of those guaranteed loans and all
those guaranteed assets are ours wasn't
that just as just as well with guys like
fail because they don't have those bad
loans there's none or is it bad because
they're not getting the exactly the
government well nipple the sucker
remember that fails Bluebonnet savings
was the most successful savings alone
and the reason was that he got his first
guaranteed payment from the government
of two hundred and seventy five million
dollars so that's why you make any loans
the government gave it $275 our two
hundred seventy five million dollars to
make up for those bad loans okay so
that's where the money's going
government saying wait a minute we got
the Resolution Trust now we have a place
to put things and we're just going to
take all that stuff back we're not going
video those guarantees anymore
Rob what is the effect of this of the
government reneging on the Southwest
plan going to be for other people like
fail that depends on the specifics of
each of the deals in other words there
were 15 transactions
okay so 15 wealthy investors took over a
total of 197 SNL's
[Music]
some of them got incredible sweetheart
deals here's an example Ronald Perelman
he got to write off all of those bad
assets that the government guaranteed
even though the government was paying
him for it and he was making a profit on
him he got to write him off as a tax
break we got a one and a half billion
billion dollar tax break okay on those
savings and loans now in addition he got
the government to agree see he wasn't
making that much profit on the savings
and loans so he had more tax break on
his savings and loan company first
gibralta and he did on any of his other
holding companies so he got the
government to agree that he could float
that tax break throughout his other
holding companies so if he made 500
million on this company back here he
just suck off five hundred million
dollar tax break from the savings and
loan side and dump it over here and he
wouldn't have to pay any tax on that
company either okay so now he's got a
sweetheart deal add the expense of the
government the tax payer know exactly I
mean when is it mild taken from the tax
fund
exactly and that's where my checking
account is my withdraw my 230 dollars
Roy no Pearlman now some of the other
Southwest plan deals have not been quite
as successful there's one bought by a
company called Lone Star Technologies
I'm not sure it was involved personally
the names but Lone Star and they haven't
been doing quite as well they didn't get
the great tax break they chose they were
a little more responsible they chose to
take on take responsibility themselves
for more of the assets and they haven't
done quite as well so they actually lost
money so the the reports I read say that
it depends on how well you negotiated
your Southwest Southwest plan
fales is going to be terminated the
others it will again they'll have to
renegotiate such a strange this whole
thing is in gambling it's like sort of a
gambling thing where the rules keep
changing and there's but and because the
rules keep changing and because uh
there's there's so much turmoil and so
much money those who are in the know
make make big bucks and if you're a
little slow if you're not right in the
heart of it or you don't have the right
connections I mean that's the other
thing you get killed I'll give you an
example okay first Gibraltar was a big
savings and loan in Houston it was going
down there were several stockholders
major stockholders two of them were
named Robert Strauss and Rickie Strauss
Oh Robbie Bob Strauss the big guys in
the Democratic Party right okay now they
were big stockholders in first Jeff
Alton they were the also the only two
stockholders to sell off their stock and
get their money out before first
Gibraltar went down now Robert Strauss
is a partner in a law firm in Dallas
called Aiken and Gump Aiken and Gump was
Ronald Perelman's
Law Firm when he took over first to
Volta so what I reconstruct is that
first two brothers in trouble it's going
to be part of the Southwest plan
Danny wall goes to Ronald Perelman and
says hey you got money you want to take
over these thrifts and they negotiate
well akin gump is the law firm that
helps those negotiations Robert Strauss
is a partner in a canon gun but he's a
big stockholder in first Gibraltar so he
hangs his money out then to do the deal
everybody loses money except straps
anyway to estimate the extent of the
financial disaster here or is it is it
just changing so rapidly that it's
really effective it's it's a it's
changing rapidly in the one of the
reasons is that remember that a lot of
this money was lost because of those
that hyper inflated equity there was an
inflated equity now the boom is dropping
out of all of those projects all those
developments all the lungs and so the
appraised value the market value of the
assets that were loaned against keeps
dropping and so you lose more and more
money so we won't know until the real
estate market drops their stops dropping
till it bottoms up so all the all the
extra amount that was as a result of all
this land flipping which was fictitious
and just fake value is going down to
where it should we shut it out with but
remember we've got another problem now
all of these assets enormous number of
assets are in the Resolution Trust
Corporation
that's the bailout right so now the Wall
Street Journal says that the Resolution
Trust will do for real estate what the
silos did for the value of the price of
corn in the Midwest remember we started
stockpiling grain and subsidizing find
out prices are way down that's right and
it's controlled now effectively the real
estate market is controlled by the
resolution
corporation so there's not going to be
much new construction because there's so
much over exactly instruction a land
prices are going down but there's a
catch here this sounds like it's good
for the consumer for the house buyer if
the prices are going down that means
more people will be able to buy houses
or office buildings but the catch is
they're having more trouble borrowing
money for these houses or for buying
development projects because of the
tight restrictions now
well that's lungs that's exactly right
correct that's what everybody or
something called a credit crunch and
part of this there are several parts to
to what you're talking about
first of all remember that the banking
industry particularly the what's called
the thrift industries and although it's
a question whether it's gonna survive
has been concentrated once again we have
a concentration into fewer and fewer
hands so the thrift industry is no
longer mom-and-pop independent entities
in each little town okay for example
here in Texas and CNB is the big bag now
enormous Bank what is really worth
Carolina
it's from North Carolina okay so they
come into Texas now you've got somebody
to bought a house four hundred thousand
dollars it took out an $80,000 note real
estate prices are dropping now their
house is worth sixty thousand but
they've got an $80,000 now
so NC NB says hey wait a minute I don't
know I want to stop that deal so they
foreclose they just say hey we're going
to stop it now before the price drops
anymore we lose more money so they're
throwing people out of their homes for
example many people in the Boone time
took out what they call mini mini perm
mortgages there were many permanent
there were short-term mortgages to be
rolled over and renegotiated after three
years or five years oh I remember that I
thought my god who who but a fool would
do that well as you're never telling
what's going to come up yeah that's
right if you don't come up because you
got to come up with a amount of money to
for the rest of them for the whole thing
at the end of this term five years or
whatever that's right and that's what's
happened if you bought a hundred
thousand dollar house and you put make
payments for five years then at the end
of that five years you've got to come up
and pay off the rest of it so they're
foreclosing on those now one of the
reasons is remember in the southwest
plan they could mark off the good assets
that they wanted to keep and they dumped
the rest on the government and they were
allowed to do that for a period of two
years after they did the deal so what
that means is if after a year and a half
they've got an asset that stopped
performing or as we were saying the
value drops and it's not well
collateralized or the people got behind
one month a couple times then they just
say well we're not going to deal with
this they write it off and there's you
know the person who's lost their
mortgage you lost their home lines of
credit that were extended have been shut
and and it gets even more ominous I've
got a friend who's got small businesses
three of them two of them are travel
agencies and over the past several years
he's done a lot of work for the
government
so IRS people need to travel around they
use his agency and so he's built up a
big stack of accounts receivable from
the
federal government he can't get paid
he's got to keep his business going so
he goes to his local bank he's worked
with him for some time and he says can
you lend me some money and I'll give you
these accounts receivable from the
government as a collateral you know the
bank said forget it I was there for the
print
so if there's any question at all
they're shutting down
and and the reason is it's not worth it
it's not worth it to them they have no
interest in the community they're huge I
don't care about facial psoriasis
I mean they're just interested in online
exactly often no on the other hand
you've got the Resolution Trust
Corporation and that's stockpiling all
of these enormous assets that hangs like
a weight over the real estate markets in
this country because they have all these
properties that can be unloaded that
preclude building new ones
exactly and now what they've just
decided to do new policy is they're
packaging
huge chunks of real estate and they're
selling them to single investors are two
single companies so what we have is in
the banking system a concentration and
in the real estate a concentration so
once again as we've seen throughout the
80s now into the 90s this enormous
concentration of wealth in a few hands
that it's also a concentration of debt
in other words you have the federal
deficit building up you have deficits
from this SNL making claims on federal
monies well that's that's something else
that's important I think to look at
really what the SNL situation has done
is Bob from the future
okay because we're selling the bonds now
but it's our children that will have to
pay them off pay the principal off and
we'll pay interest for 30 years those
mortgage rally right it's a mortgage for
the entire economy that's right now the
interesting question is who buys the
Treasury bonds and it appears that it's
one-third foreign investors and the
other two-thirds are split roughly in
half financial institutions and
corporate capitalists which is again
concentrating property in small amounts
of people's exactly I mean we're
subsidizing and it's like it's the four
terminal and get capital it's like
serfdom
I mean we're tithing a percentage of our
taxes which is going to rise it's
already a third of the budget right and
the deficit the debt is right so we're
gonna have to make these interest
payments and then our kids are going to
have to pay it off and they're going to
pay it to those guys the wealthy who
benefited from this whole thing to start
out with exactly could this be a
conspiracy of the rich doctor
concentrate capital in there well and
try new UI New Jersey we've had some
Republicans that captured the state in
the 1980s and the 1980s to represent the
interests of big corporations and big
business you don't think they were
putting through policies it might have
just been afib them and their friends
and the expense [ __ ] to everyone else no
no they wouldn't do that something like
that could happen in a great democracy
well as I said earlier I'm not going to
outline any specific conspiracy theory
but boy it sure makes you that's the
effects especially if you have a war
with a rock to deflect attention send
this kind of
thing I mean this brings the whole
question of the media and to what extent
has de media explained any of this
complex story that you're telling I've
been getting bits and pieces sometimes
from the New York Times and mainly the
alternative press but this is one of the
most underreported stories of the
century I know it's funny because the
savings and loan crisis is a is a vastly
reported story but it's the it's this
it's a surface look and what details of
individual corruption without seeing the
structural factors behind this the
policy decisions the games people were
playing the effects of these games
exactly and a lot of people are going to
be hurt by this I mean this is just a
disaster
and you know we're in pretty good shape
here in Texas I mean we have all these
empty office buildings that eventually
will fill up and you know all that money
that was being siphoned off a lot of it
was siphoned off into Texas but what's
going to happen in the Northeast or in
some other place where the money that
wasn't sent and now of course there's a
focus on the regional effects of the
bailout those people are going to be
taxed just like us and they're going to
send the money down here to pay off for
the wheelers and dealers in this region
it's creating these big gambling debts
exactly right and so there's a Phil
Gramm up in the Senate was was booed and
hissed last the week before they they
stopped they quit for the summer uh
because he suggested that they
redistribute some community development
grants and I mean they were a mad at him
they were mad they said some vile things
to that guy what effect is all this had
on various public institutions or strata
such as schools that are to rely on
taxes property taxes for there's all
this and all these empty buildings that
no tax is coming from them what's
happening well that's an interesting
question
our local tax assessor named Cecilia
Burke says that the Resolution Trust of
course has to pay the taxes on all those
properties it's part of the carrying
costs really yes of course they own it
that's part of the bail out expense the
government owns all these knowledge it's
all these non-functioning things they've
gotta pay taxes on the Resolution Trust
has the rough cost of the assets in the
Resolution Trust are twenty five percent
annually carrying charges just carrying
charges to manage to keep track of and
pay the taxes and that's how much a year
well if they've got what are they got
now three hundred billion or two hundred
two hundred billion in assets that's
fifty billion a year just in carrying
charges that disappears so you're asking
about the total cost there are some
folks who are now talking about two
trillion and that's I'm up in that
category that's what I think it's going
to be if you include all these other
charges now the problem is that the
Resolution Trust according to Cecilia
Burke our local tax assessor is a
deadbeat and not paying a lot man yep
that means is that services schools
everything that depends on Roberts all
the water designer actual stuff in the
communities the federal government is
paying the taxes through the Resolution
Trust to the local community and if they
don't pay and the funds aren't there
exactly as they would have expected
these business and development
corporations to pay off that's right
plus you combine that with a credit
crunch a contraction of credit and shuts
down small businesses people's homes get
foreclosed on the unemployment so the
tax base goes out there too I mean you
don't have all this money flowing around
so you can't tax it this sounds to me
like a downward spiral oh and this is
something worse than the Great
Depression is coming it was just based
on stock market machination xand and
some overinflated you know businesses
well the effect this sounds structurally
much more is this a middle class is
going to disappear more and more and
more
living in poverty in fact there was a
report recently in the paper that 32
percent of the people in this country
are effectively living in poverty
because their shelter poor when after
they pay their mortgage they don't have
enough left for the basic necessities of
life as defined by the federal
Department field Health and Human
Services
so that's 78 million 78 million people
in this country are already at the
poverty level and we're just started
we're just starting do you think this is
going to be sort of slow attrition or it
was going to be a dramatic crash like
the stock market crash it took a 1929
that was sort of a dramatic event that
led to bank closings and then the
foreclosures what do you think this is
going to be a slower attrition that will
be a little harder to see and to figure
out well I think that it's going to be
slow for two reasons number one the
financial markets are much better
regulated now you know they've got these
automatic shut offs if the Dow drops so
far and they have other kinds of
regulatory internal checks on the
crashing the other factor is that we've
got what is called it has been called a
rolling recession so the Midwest goes
down it bottoms out starts to slide up a
little bit and then Texas goes down it's
the bottoms out and then New England
starts to goods distributing the
depression or recession to different
parts of the country I think that the
key problems are if there is a big crash
it will come from the international
markets right now the dollar is still
the standard of currency in global
markets and the Japanese are harder foot
to get off the dollar standard
and go to a more independent measure and
when that happens our currency is going
to be worth less than the Argentine
reality they call their money
I mean it's we're going to be look like
third world already a cab ride from the
airport in Tokyo cost $250 so it's like
a Mexican peasant coming up here and
taking a cab ride trying to pay in pesos
and it's a quarter of his annual
earnings all right well now if you go to
Tokyo and you take a cab
down down 250 bucks well it sounds to me
like we need a war with Iraq to describe
the tension that of all of these
economic woes that this is more
entertainment for the people seeing
battles in the desert and hostage
struggles and this is sort of a popular
culture you know good versus evil
sandwich we're good and they're evil
there's Hitler out there to fight
whereas if you look to see who the bad
guys are in the savings and loan this
whole financial debacle it's the
establishment it's the Congress the
presidency the regulator's the wheelers
and dealers the entirety of the system
is implicated in this well you know if
you go back and look at economic history
like the Great Depression or others that
may or may not have been engineered by
big bankers like Pierpont Morgan etc so
frequently when things happened it
looked like economic forces we're doing
it whereas other people who go back and
look at it later and they find out hey
there were certain manipulations that
were going on that resulted in these
things and then what happened when the
economy would collapse or there was a
big depression a lot of people were hurt
but the big guys of the top would always
prosper because they would go in and buy
real estate and other property at very
and on various businesses at very low
cost
so that they would really benefit and
there would be more and more
concentration of ownership up at the top
as a matter of fact I read an article in
one of the Wall Street Journal somebody
said a lot of the very wealthy people
and wealthy and financial institutions
have been building up an enormous war
chest of extra money so that when the
big crash comes they can come in and buy
up all all this stuff that will be fire
sale
there's my famous quotation attributed
to Baron on Rothschild one of the great
famous bankers of all time and that
quotation is the best time to buy is
when blood is running in the streets and
that's where we are